[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau de l'année date
à dire je reçois aujourd'hui
l'explorateur jean louis etienne qui
publie explorateur des océans aux
éditions pol scène on parlera également
de sa prochaine expédition sur le polar
pod le navire verticale qu'il est conçu
pour l'océan austral alain saxe le métro
send et dieu créa le swing au théâtre de
la comédie bastille le nouveau spectacle
des swing cocktails et pierre verville
pour son roman la ville d âne un roman
noir avec ses ficelles de toujours mais
à la sauce d'aujourd'hui et l'on
commence tout de suite pas les images
que vous avez choisie pour illustrer
notre époque la vôtre pierre lavoie 6
et bien c'est une drôlerie de notre
époque que ce sont deux tours où on a
inventé de deux mètres des des forêts et
des champs perchée sur des immeubles
alors celles ci ont été une relative
réussite et son habile en toutes celles
qui ont suivi que ce soit à paris ou en
chine ou ailleurs ça se développe
et ça marche pas très bien ah bon vous
avez une explication jour où etienne
pourquoi ça marche pas bien je ne sais
pas mais je trouve ça intéressant ouais
on a vu on a vu pendant le coc vide où
tous les gens qui ont mis avait quelque
chose qui pousse et sur le balcon ils
sont tous tellement heureux peu et bien
sûr oui c'est vrai qu'on en voit de plus
en plus moi je croyais que ça marchait
bien non non ça fonctionne pas du tout
soit ça c'est sèche soit ya des
problèmes d'irrigation soyez dd ça c'est
la même chose
c'est trop basse et donc donc tout ça
fonctionne quand il ya trop d'eau par
exemple il ya beaucoup de moustiques le
goutte à mort en chine en chine il avait
son nom construit plusieurs tout un tout
à l'ensemble et
fidèle membre ça a beaucoup poussé ça ne
s'est pas dessécher pour le coup mais
c'est ont envahi par les moustiques ce
qui fait qu il y avait six tours je
croyais au départ il reste trois
habitants dans les tours donc c'est un
petit peu quand même pour bode l'amopa
garde l'image d'elle un sexe maintenant
elles sont très mignonne sa dette un peu
cette image là non ouais mais c'est
magnifique ça d'abord d'une émotion
incroyable c'est l'éternelle lutte des
classes finalement ce sont les femmes de
ménage du théâtre qui est pas toujours
de norman rockwell les femmes de ménage
qui essaye de comprendre pourquoi ils
font ménage c'est pour visiblement l oms
sont tombés sur deux sur le programme du
théâtre et ses saillies de voir voilà
que ce qui se passe le soir dans ce
théâtre où elles n'ont sans doute jamais
été donc il ya vraiment deux des
travailleurs de l'ombre des travailleurs
du jour et les lumières de la nuit et
fait qu ils nient une illustration
norman rockwell ça n'est pas une photo
comme d'un an seulement et vous jean
louis etienne votre image les voici mais
la fracturation des formules à sierre
qui s'accélère et les glaciers des les
calottes glaciaires perdre beaucoup
effectivement à l'heure actuelle ça
s'accélère ça amène de l'eau à la mer ça
fait monter le niveau et c'est en train
de perturber les équilibres climatiques
en fait que c'est une conséquence non a
ouvert la porte du frigo en a au nom
manqué de va manquer vous raconter
d'ailleurs dans votre livre dont on va
parler tout de suite un nom vous
retrouvez face à ces ondes et dans les
années 90 voitures antarctique
infections carrément un immeuble oui oui
un immeuble de 45 et de 15 étages et oui
oui c'est des fronts sur l'appel salle
et les plateformes les plateformes
glaciaires l'eichelthal anglais on dit
c'est à dire que par exemple le
groenland ou l'antarctique au sud ce
sont des calottes de glace sont des
immenses glaciers playe par gravité
comme tous les glaciers y descendent et
quand il arrive sur la mer y flotte et
ça va très loin des fois que 300 400 500
km
et quand ça se coupe au bout ça fait des
icebergs tabulaire parce qu'ils sont
plats comme des tables un bout mais ce
qui se passe là et cette image illustre
ces les fronts les fronts glacière et
qui descendent jusque là mais rapidement
et qui s'accélère et bien commençons
[Musique]
jean louis etienne vous êtes médecin
explorateur entrepreneurs d'expéditions
lointaines vous êtes le premier homme à
avoir atteint le pôle nord en solitaire
en 86 après 63 jours de marche vous avez
également réussi en traîneau cette fois
la plus longue traversée de
l'antarctique
6300 kilomètres avant de la traversée en
ballon en 2010 aujourd'hui vous publiez
explorateurs de ses hanches et possède
une façon de nous rappeler que vous êtes
plus marin que therrien finalement plus
terriens que marin aujourd'hui un peu
plus marin que je n'étais rien je suis
dans le tarn sympa département agricole
si vous voulez et vous n'avez vu la mer
qu'à dix ans oui qu'à dix ans et s'était
profondément ennuyeux parce que c'était
la plage je n'aime toujours pas la plage
etc n'est pas du tout ça donc on faisait
une journée de voiture pour aller se
cramer sur la plage on revenait on était
rouge chaud comme ça bref j'aime et pas
du tout ça sauf quand j'ai découvert un
homme apaisé un peu que la mer c'était
peut-être un espace de liberté immense
quoi un loyer et à sont là je commençais
à m'intéresser comme j'étais bricoleur
je me dis plate je pourrai faire mon
bateau etc et l'idée est partie de la
wii en 76 vous devez vous êtes embarqué
comme médecin sur le club méditerranée
le magnifique bateau de d'alain colas
qui deviendra plus tard célèbre sous le
nom du phocéa c'est elle et avant ça
c'était un bateau de bernard tapie ah
oui voilà et avant ça c'était pen duick
pdm ans avait été bénéfique puisque l
aco là qu'on va voir en photo était un
mort a été un équipier de huy de terry
wey et
c'est extraordinaire de commencer par
alain colas oui et alain colas en fait
moi je rentrais j'étais avec le père
jaouen on est arrivé à new york pour le
bicentenaire le père jaouen avec sa
clientèle de jeunes un peu en difficulté
ont représenté la france
cadets toxiques aux toxicomanes et à new
york y avait alain colas qui venait de
perdre à transat avec 181 contre tabarly
contre tabarly il voulait rentrer en
battant le record de l'atlantique
seulement il avait une grave grave
blessure à la cheville il avait besoin
de médecins et donc je suis passé du
père jaouen accola pour revenir ces sacs
poubelles avec les coups de bol oui
aujourd'hui vous vous dites si vous
aviez pas fait cette traversée vous
n'auriez peut-être fait aucune des
autres
c'est à dire ça a commencé avec le père
jaouen moi j'étais médecin des affaires
maritimes en méditerranée pour vos
services nationale je rencontre le père
jaouen avec son bateau leur avis et son
équipage il me dit si ça vous intéresse
on cherche un médecin pour traverser
l'atlantique ça a été ma promo premier
embarquement avec le père jaouen et je
moi je voulais naviguer j'avais cette
envie je me laissais rien mais j'ai
commencé avec jaouen tabarly cola et
puis après j'ai eu mon bateau ouais
parce que quand même qu l'appui tabarly
re tabarly voulez vous le décrivez
longuement dans votre livre il a
toujours été très impressionnante à
barlin mais on a l'impression qu'ils
commandent son équipage en silence
s'étaient dirigés par le silence tabarly
voyez j'avais un très bon chef de quart
qui étaient filés poupon qui était bien
un grand marin et donc j'étais jour il
l'est toujours les jours que
rencontrerait souvent en antarctique oui
j'en ai parlé au passé normale est
toujours un grand pardon et donc c'était
lui qui allait dire à éric dit non ça
ferait chier où il faudrait peut-être
faire quelque chose eric montée regarder
il disait un truc ou et on va prendre un
ris mais le mec qui était à côté qui
avait entendu en foire il s'était pas
éric doneys voilà les derricks parler
très doucement il dirigé en silence et
il le faisait bien s'est il était c'est
génial dans la conception des bateaux
wibree penduick csn d'ailleurs quand il
gagne la transat c'est tout beau des
super fait il est super fier wiltord les
anglo saxons on verra raison on parle
toujours du marin mais l'architecte
naval visionnaire ouais les premiers
foïs et lui les trimarans qu'a utilisée
après alain colas pour le tout ça
c'était lui c'était un ingénieur un
architecte naval spontané qu'il
connaissait la mer il voyait un peu ce
qu'il pouvait être le mieux adapté quoi
alors vous vous allez après avoir
atteint le pôle nord en solitaire que
vous dites maintenant il faut se
construisent mon bateau pourquoi là où
j'allais dire là où parce que j'avais
pensé avant j'avais pensé avant j'avais
été au groenland et en rentrant du
groenland je me suis dit comme l'autre
bateau choisi il me faudra un bateau
d'expédition et le pôle nord c'était une
pour moi
soixante trois jours en solitaire en 86
n'y a pas dit il n'y a pas de téléphone
pas le gps donc c'est une solitude
intense voyez on sait pas où elle pôle
nord aussi en plus il n'ya rien au cold
wave et du tout la dérive c'est donc
mais jamais sur qui on est et on voit là
donc c'est un peu par la navigation que
j'y suis arrivé et c'était tellement
soulagement j'étais tellement heureux
d'avoir réussi cette expédition je me
suis dit ça ça va être ma vie montée des
expéditions et tout de suite c'est a été
la construction du bateau antartica qui
s'appelle tara aujourd'hui voilà
antarctique est qu'on va voir ici qu'est
ce qu'ils avaient de spécial antarctique
alors antarctique a été fait pour étude
et l'océan arctique un homme qui est
couvert de glace couvert de banquise et
donc les bateaux qui sont allés pour
explorer vers le pôle nord ils sont tous
fait broyer sauf un le bateau de nansen
norvégien parce qu'il était rond comme
ça et quand vous êtes pris dans la glace
si vous êtes renvoyé vous vous esquivez
et d'un atlantique a été sur ce principe
là quand on le regarde de face on voit
que lille est tout rond comme ça et il a
fait la dérive traversée de l'arctique
sans aucune blessure donc celui-là il
était fait pour l'étude de l'océan
arctique alors votre prochain projet
c'est le polar pod votre prochaine
expédition fin 2023 normalement le polar
todd mois chez première fois que je les
ai pourquoi il est cette forme un bateau
verticale on va le découvrir et je
trouve absolument extraordinaire à
l'envoyer ça c'est fait pour étudier
l'océan autour de l'antarctique et au
sud on est au sud et donc les fameux 40e
50e hurlants si vous voulez les marins
du vendée globe il passe tous les quatre
ans mais les chercheurs les
scientifiques n'y vont pas souvent et
élise tous on a besoin de mesures in
situ de longue durée ça veut dire on a
besoin de s'installer sur cet océan à
nous cerne de tempête s'ouvrait et donc
avec un bureau d'études de lorient a
chip east et on est arrivé à la
conclusion qu'il fallait un long tube
grand flotteur ça c'est la partie
émergée où on habite il volait mes
dessous il ya 80 m qui nous permet
d'être pris dans des eaux stable voyez
l'agitation l état la surface là où la
mer est devant se rencontrent et donc
sur ce navire verticale à la surface
d'un treillis c'est à dire trois buts
papier et donc la mère passe facilement
à travers eux n'est pas percuter voyez
comme peut l'être un bateau normale du
ciment c'est du béton et de l'acier
c'est de l'acier les grosses masses
convoi will eux
mêmes la nacelle est en acier spécial
parce que le bureau veritas qui a
certifié le navire les ingénieurs
d'inventer la la la la vague 50 nal une
vague de statistiques
bac d'algorithmes ne voyait donc 1,38
mètre de haut de sakho l'arrivée ça peut
arriver sur l'ordinateur ouais
ça commence là mais comme l'ordinateur
la lie il faut pouvoir affronter cette
vague là et donc on a fait une maquette
spéciales adaptées aux vagues peuvent
faire ifremer à braise et voilà donc il
se couche comme ça et elle le culbuto il
se redresse mais quand on est dans
l'habitacle oui c'est très stable très
stable ah oui on a fait des études de
mal de transport parce que c'est très
beau à l'intérieur enfin moi j'ai eu des
illustrations oui j'aurais très très
stable alors l'impression qu'on va être
heurté si vous voulez sur cette image
mais on peut être heurté mais il ya 80
mètres sous l'eau qui sont qui échappent
si vous voulez à l'agitation cette photo
il ya un petit personnage il est à
l'échelle il est à l'échelle oui oui
cela donne une idée de la taille on est
à dix mètres au dessus de l'eau et
l'ensemble une venue alors j'ai enfin
compris il existe au panneau rayonnant
non alors c'est l'état qui finance la
construction ouais ils feraient mère est
maître d'ouvragé c'est un appel d'offres
chantiers publics et donc le chantier
devrait être signé après des
consultations un an de consultations
auprès de nombreux chantiers à la mi
janvier on connaîtra le d'accord est
normalement fin 2023 fin 2023 il est à
l'eau et on part début 2024 ça c'est le
meilleur qui vient de partir d'où
l'afrique du sud ah oui au sud de
l'afrique ce que l'on imagine bien
rester là mais je n'imagine pas naviguer
ce alors dans bezos pour le pour des
longues distances on le met à
l'horizontale on le tire à l'horizontale
des cas il bat laon le ballast il
bascule et puis il est anglais là et
c'est la persévérance qui est le voyez
vieira vite ailleurs pas ce que va faire
deux fois le tour du monde c'est à dire
deux fois le tour de l'antarctique ça va
durer trois ans personne va rester trois
ans il ya des relève d'équipage tous les
deux mois avec un navire et qui
s'appelle persévérance qui est à l'image
du voyage et qui est très beau aussi un
bateau qui est qui est taillé pour les
cinquantièmes voyez avec à l'arrière une
passerelle pour faire le va et vient
entre le polar pod et le
navire-ravitailleur on va changer les
équipages j'aime la nourriture des
pièces détachées de matériel si fou
voilà et ça fait combien de temps vous
en rêviez de l'un et l'autre puisqu'ils
sont inséparables ah ça fait onze ans
maintenant ah oui ça fait onze ans que
je travaille dessus c'est pour ça que le
navire habitent ailleurs s'appelle
persévérant c'est l'illustration du long
chemin mais le découragement est un test
permet d'affranchir quoi c'est tout le
temps comme ça il faut résister à la
tentation de l'abandon sur des projets
comme ça que m mais c'est des projets
aussi vous avez besoin de sponsors voilà
alors l'état finance la construction
comme ali et moi j'ai la charge de du
financement de l'expédition en elle même
est la grosse part du travail la
technique c'est les ingénieurs et les
financements c'est moi si vous voulez
pas son temps à séduire à essayer de
convaincre il y aura un magnifique
projet pédagogique c'est pas une course
voyez c'est pas c'est pas un challenge
c'est pas en voyant c'est la planète qui
va gagner voyez donc c'est ça que les
caisses mais qu'est ce qu'on va observer
vous avez raison 1
c'est le principal puits de carbone
océanique de la planète à lui seul cet
océan absorbe la moitié du gaz
carbonique qu'absorbe l'ensemble des
océans parce que c'est une surface d'eau
froide et le co2 se dissout davantage
dans l'eau froide ensuite ce navire on
n'a pas de moteur
le polar poids n'a pas de moteur pas de
groupe électrogène il est silencieux on
va mettre des hydrophones des micros
sous l'eau et par acoustique on va faire
l'inventaire de la faune parce qu'on
connaît la signature sonore 10 de toutes
les espèces qui a une balle est bleu
tiens un orque des manchots empereur
voyez donc par écoute passif permanente
ça c'est l'inventaire de la faune par
acoustique troisièmement refaire bien
sur des échantillons d'eau de mer qu'est
ce qu'on trouve là bas si loin et
pesticides des organochlorés des métaux
lourds on va pour alors que personne n'y
habite un personnes y habitent on est
très très loin des activités
industrielles mais il y a le brassage
aérien de l'air l'air transporte partout
multitude de polluants que l'on met à la
surface des chants par exemple on
retrouve un peu partout et donc ça ça
fait partie du ca c'est la partie
aventure sur cette image là c'est
effectivement les relèves d'équipage qui
se feront à en plein océan si vous
voulez donc là ça demande des bons
marins et des gens passionnés pour vous
serez vous allez devenir un des
meilleurs connaisseurs de l'antarctique
je le disais tout à l'heure vous l'avez
traversée avec un chien ville avait
survolé en ballons là vous avez un
ballon c'était au pôle nord mais je veux
remercier avec des chiens j'y suis allé
quand j'avais antarctique a souvent
c'est un cetain l'endroit où je me suis
épanoui mais il est très difficile d'y
accéder si j'ai bien compris oui
l'antarctique oui parce que si vous
voulez en leur univers et à la banquise
bien sûr puisque ça ça gèle très loin et
ensuite allez tu essaies tu sais il ya
des icebergs ce qui est difficile si
vous voulez c'est de ces journées là où
les scientifiques attendent une présence
c'est à dire entre 50 et 55 sud voyez
c'est à dire les fameux 50èmes hurlants
ça bouge dont il ya très peu de mission
parce que c'est loin si goûteux
difficile d'accès et nous on va offrir
aux chercheurs savaient plus à 13 il au
fait la zil cette plateforme qui est
extrêmement confortable donc je vous le
disais on a fait des études du mal de
transport parce qu'il ya des gens qui
vont travailler dessus donc ce qui nous
rend malades souvent sur un bateau se
rappelle le pylône m'envoyer ça monte ça
redescend là ils pilonnent pas il est
très stable c'est la mère qui bouge à
côté mes pilotes pas donc on est ce
qu'il ya c'est qu'on a de temps en temps
on le voit bien sur cette image se
l'océan qui entourait autour ce coup un
petit peu mais l'ensemble de la
structure est là haut on a une secousse
comme ça on appelle ça des mouvements de
la ces qui correspond à ce que vous
ressentez quand vous allez dans le tgv
quand vous allez au bar voyez c'est 0,3
g et c'est tout à fait compatible avec
eux et pas de risques qu'un alors que
une baleine s'amuse avec non non je
pense qu'on attend on entendra
volontiers le calmar géant qui pourrait
peut-être colossal mais en fait non nous
on va doucement voyons n'est pas un
bateau qui va très vite et qui risque de
percuter un mammifère mais je pense
comme il ya sur cette image en bois être
une attraction pour ces espèces qui
virent le coin qu'est ce que c'est ce
truc là qu'on est dans jules verne a
fait jules verne ouais absolument jules
verne c'est pour ça qu'on peut faire un
projet pédagogique très attractif parce
qu'on peut raconter de belles histoires
avec ça je peux me permettre mais je
vous embrasse une magnifique des
ententes jean louis etienne depuis tant
d'années qui nous fait rêver il a l'air
toujours tellement enflammés et
optimiste mais vous nous c'est qu'on est
totalement désespéré angoissé vous vous
rendez vous par rapport à l'avenir sauf
la gueule ça c'est écouter par rapport à
l'avenir ouais mais sans sans le moindre
espoir ça lemoine culture des solutions
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas l'espoir et on
nous sert beaucoup trop souvent ce qui
va pas mais sincèrement au nord bien sûr
qu'on a la conscience de la situation on
a l'intelligence des solutions des
solutions elles seront comportementale
mais elles seront technologique entre va
passer des voitures à moteur thermique à
électrique ce que je veux dire on a
besoin de technologies on va avoir
besoin d'ingénieurs d'intelligence
humaine voyez donc ce qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait avoir la sagesse et de mettre
en oeuvre les solutions le plus
rapidement possible notamment le charbon
qui est l'ennemi de meuron du climat
quand on sait encore que 80% de
l'énergie planétaire 80% c'est encore
des fossiles dont une grande part de
charbon c'est ça le les rôles ou ceux
aussi qui pensent pouvoir le remplacer
par
par du solaire ou de l'éolien
ambitions d'ailleurs la nouvelle
coalition allemande qui voulaient se
débarrasser du charbon mais en le
remplaçant par 80% vous non je pense que
le les renouvelables l'éolien voit y
avait tous les renouvelables on va dire
pourront couvrir les besoins domestiques
mon avis d'une population qui est très
éduqués à la préciosité de l'énergie on
n'a aucune idée de ce que l'on compte de
dépenses en économie vous avez le franc
ou l'euro océan millau 10 millions
milliard on a une idée à peu près loyers
en énergie vous dites à quelqu'un
kilowatts mégawatts gigawatts térawatts
jean marc jancovici à lui il est sur lui
dont mais il n'a que le clip a eu par
exemple moi français nous quatre on
consomme à peu près l'énergie développée
par six en esclaves chacun oui c'est
comme si on avait six ans esclaves
qu'ils pouvaient pour nous en permanence
parce que la nature humaine si vous
voulez mais pas d'une puissance
extraordinaire on voit on le voit sur
les coureurs du tour de france par
exemple qu'en disait revient 400 watts
il ya 400 watts et le tiers de votre
machine à café quand il arrive à 400
watts il sort au bout du bout et on sait
les soupçonne déjà de l'énergie c'est
quelque chose qui est difficile à
évaluer les renouvelables d'accord il
faudrait le plus vite possible ralentir
les fossiles et le nucléaire peu égal
mc2 c'est un pur produit de
l'intelligence humaine on pourra pas
s'en passer malheureusement ces malades
et on en a fait bomber au lieu de faire
purement dit de l'intelligence l'océan
vous dites que c'est le grand régulateur
du climat mondial oui grand régulateur
parce que pour deux raisons j'ai évoqué
la capacité qu'a cet océan absorber le
gaz carbonique le co2 donc il soustrait
pas du co2 que l'on envoie et
deuxièmement l'océan absorbe
93% de l'excès de chaleur l'excès de
chaleur du réchauffement climatique 93%
et donc les conséquences c'est que les
tempêtes tropicales de polynésie où
d'ailleurs deviennent des cyclones il ya
une augmentation de l'intensité parce
que le sérail plus chaud les épisodes
cévenols de la méditerranée devienne
aujourd'hui ces immenses inondations que
l'on connaît tout simplement parce qu'à
la fin de l'hiver l'eau est chaude
s'évapore amène de l'hygrométrie de
l'humidité et j'y arrive r ça donc c'est
un grand grand régulateur du climat par
sa capacité à soustraire le co2 et à
réguler la chaleur il va falloir quand
même m il ya un conditionnement
psychologique avant d'aller s'installer
sur polar pod des marins des marins vont
forcément débat mais les scientifiques
aussi alors c'est beaucoup de
techniciens sur toile le fonctionnement
c'est la station spatiale la même chose
non il ya beaucoup de capteurs et peu de
monde mais les gens qui sont là il va
falloir qu il faut qu'il connaisse
comment on répare comme on change que
mon calibre donc c'est surtout
ingénieurs techniciens et on envoie la
donner à terre aux chercheurs c'est
comme ça que ça va vous allez y allez
combien de temps vous moi je vais y
aller au début bien sûr parce que je
suis curieux de voir ce que c'est mon
rêve
mon rêve ça serait pas de passer deux
mois sur sur chaque océan indien le
pacifique et l'atlantique une chaire
l'enverra deux mois oui c'est une
rotation ouais c'est une rotation donc
que c'est ça le temps que l'on veut est
passé sur mer parce que j'en avais fait
des traversées
wheels et surtout surtout sur l'océan
arctique donc sur la mer gelée c'est le
plus long 63 jours et la traversée du
pôle sud c'était c'était sept mois mais
là j'étais en équipe mais le nord
j'étais en solitaire c'est intense le
solitaire c'est ça que on a des
ressources que l'on n'imagine pas si
vous voulez courdent explorateur des
océans pour raconter votre votre
expédition qui par tonne ah oui petit
minuscule ça c'est une de mes parenthèse
tropicale pour toujours des régions
polaires mais une parenthèse tropicale
clipperton ces nano français renault
coralliens peut tout petit 1 2 km sur
toit en plein pacifique personne n'y vit
ces territoires français 6e les
grillades oiseaux kazim beaucoup
beaucoup oiseaux c'est la plus grande
colonie au monde de fous masqués il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'oiseaux et on est
allé faire un inventaire naturaliste
l'ont habité quatre mois sur cette île
déserte mais bon j'étais en famille avec
mes enfants étaient tout petits neuf
mois et 3 ans donc c'était pourri sans
souliers de même pas en plus non ils
sont trop il s'est dit il était un peu
trop jeune quoi donc c'était déjà bien
ses expéditions ses engagements ses
parenthèses du monde mais et vous vous
êtes ennuyer ou pas sur qui personne
jamais mais aucun n'a à aucun moment ils
se retrouvent le plus formidable il est
rare que je m'ennuie coué et quand je
n'ai rien à faire dans un coin où
l'attend je m'endors et sans force ayant
donc jeu mais je peux mettre des
parenthèses voyez quand je sens qu'il ya
géré on attend dans une salle d'attenté
sérieux je m'endors mais sinon j'ai
toujours une quelque chose et je disais
tout à l'heure que peut-être maintenant
je j'aimerais être écrivain mais
romancier réunit le roman on n'a plus
besoin de voyager beaucoup voyez on
voyage avec son roman avec ses
personnages avec son équipage voyait il
n'y a pas de le nôtre façon d'explorer
et c'est une exploration et c'est ce que
je dis à tout le monde soyez les
explorateurs engagé de votre temps c'est
ça qui est intéressant la plupart du
temps aujourd'hui on dit d'un bep moi je
m'ennuie jamais ce parce qu'on a un
lecteur de dvd la radio les télévisions
j'ai vu des trucs là enfin clipperton ça
devait pas fonctionner terrible non non
non je pense pas que ça vous ennuie
spécialement non c'est mon ambition une
autre passion c'est le bricolage ou
utiliser mes dix doigts c'est ce qui m'a
sauvé d'ailleurs dans ma scolarité parce
que je voyais moi j'avais pas les notes
pour entrer en sixième et donc j'ai fait
l'apprentissage professionnel j'ai fait
un cap2 tourneur fraiseur après j'ai
fait médecine parce qu'on va pousser
vers le bas de la une de match
bienveillante a dit mais ce gars voilà
donc j'ai passé le bac dont tourneur
fraiseur ça peut devenir un bon
chirurgien a way justement mais cet
interne en chirurgie après le pdi
attendant que les délices des plaques
débrouille
j'étais à l'aise mais b il y avait ce
désir d'expédition qui était un gamin
qui était dans la campagne gérée la
campagne j'aime et vivre dehors mais en
tant que médecin vous avez véritablement
exercées au cours de toutes ces
expéditions oui oui à l'expédition
par chance rarement et le médecin est là
pour orienter avec tabarly et colas vous
êtes là en tant que médecin mais oui que
vous soyez personnes non vont tous bien
oui tout le monde allait bien on est là
pour prendre une décision si jamais il
ya une décision à prendre en pleine mer
si vous voulez rejoindre la côte pour
faire soigner quelqu'un sinon la
médecine si vous voulez le mât elle m'a
mis le pied à l'étrier de ses
expéditions dont je rêvais quand j'étais
petit ça a été mon vecteur pour entrer
dans dans ses expéditions
explorateur des océans
le nouveau livre de jean louis etienne
c'est paru chez paul scène et votre
expédition normalement c'est fin 2023
fin 2003 début 2000 arcade ouais merci
jean louis etienne je vous libère parce
que je sais que vous devez être ailleurs
juste après la chambre des sous on va
friser chercher des sous ou les
constants là on fait une pause au revoir
jean loup et bientôt
[Musique]
jean louis etienne a dû nous quitter
mais nous sommes toujours avec k
bervillé est elle un sac ce qui met en
scène et dieu créa le swing au théâtre
de la comédie bastille un spectacle
musical avec les swings cocktail c'est
un peu bizarre non d'attribuer à dieu un
art low swing créé par les jazzmen
américains
c'est un peu comme si on disait et dieu
créa la cinquième de beethoven on est
certain du principe que dieu a tout créé
faut vraiment partir de ce point de vue
là
c'est une blague en plus c'est une
blague aussi sur par rapport à dieu créa
la femme puisque c'est un groupe féminin
après panier par un homme un pianiste
mais c'est c3 mais il veut d'isa et dieu
créa le swing c'est vraiment de
l'appropriation culturelle absolument
dit c'est ce qu'on essaye de raconter
que le elle commence en tenue de femme
de la préhistoire est quand même le son
la musique la première musique elle
n'est forcément là dans les cavernes en
tapant vont les choses on entend les
sons en poussant des cris
c'était déjà du jeu les swing cocktail
je vous propose de regarder le teaser de
ce spectacle teaser
[Musique]
dans le
ballon il me montre les dents à croquer
la fortune haribo c'est l'hallu à
bouffer
montez dans la non
[Musique]
c'est là
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les swing cocktail se sont fait
connaître avec amour swing débotté
elles reprennent donc des titres comme
ça des tubes en général accompagnées par
un piano qui est-ce qui vous a intéressé
chez elle à naussac alors moi j'ai mis
en scène le quatuor pendant 25 ans
c'étaient les hommes s'ils étaient des
hommes vous avez tout compris et j'avais
dit que je ne prenne le quatuor c'était
un an un an et demi de retard a lu
quelques molière d'ailleurs oui c'est
vrai
le grand bonheur et je m'étais dit que
je ne mettrai plus en scène des groupes
parce que j'avais tout fait et puis j'ai
reçus dont j'entends reçoit c'est la
magie total des projets comment ines
j'ai reçu ça et j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait une excellence musicale absolue
focale et et en plus c'était
effectivement la possibilité de ne pas
investiguer le répertoire féminin dont
j'avais été privé pendant intrigant et
moi je suis un fou de toutes les
musiques de toutes les chansons de
toutes les contrées et je me suis dit on
va pouvoir voilà visiter tout leur
répertoire féminin et faire un spectacle
à la fois sur le swing est à la fois sur
la condition féminine au fur et à mesure
du temps qui passe et au fur et à mesure
des gens qui ont écrit les chansons sur
les femmes mais oui parce que j'allais
dire le swing c'est pas non plus y en a
pas tant que ça j'en ai pu dire et dieu
créa la pop absolument mais bon c'est ce
qui les distingue alors que ce sont des
ddd attrapé qu'ils peuvent chanter du
classique de 9,6 à fond mais en fait
leur origine c'est d'être dans la
continuité de ces groupes féminins
vocaux de récents qui ont et qu'ils ont
beaucoup beaucoup swinguer s'est vérifié
il faut penser aux andrews sisters dans
les années 40 comme ça qui chantait tout
les 3 et qu'il y avait un peu le même
timbre
et quand on fait un trio féminin comme
ça est ce que les trois doivent avoir le
même timbre ah non alors justement alors
après il ya de la magie cette vision c3
c6 tueur totalement différente et
annabelle se dit thibault qui est leur
directrice musicale fait des
arrangements qui époustouflant tout le
monde est d'ailleurs maintenant l'autre
jour où on est en train de préparer un
nouveau pianiste parce que le spectre
beaucoup de succès donc on va
démultiplier les représentations et il
n'y avait que l'une d'entre elles
présentent à la répétition et pour la
première fois c'était morgan tout alain
macabiau et pour la préfète j'ai entendu
soldats doit sa vraie voix nous disons
mais c'est incroyable elle chante pas
une seule fois
les limites au dic mais dans l'harmonie
tout ça se mélange merveilleusement et
c'est la première chose qui épouse
souffre le public c'est ils sont
scotchés par là par une virtuosité
musicale mais alors là la facilité ce
serait qu'elle enchaîne les titres
comment faire donc justement soit pas un
simple concert c'est pas non plus une
comédie musicale il n'y a pas de parties
jouées ou tout à coup on parle
normalement c'est un spectacle musical
heures comment on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est ce qu'on met pour éviter le
concert eh bien on fait exactement le
contraire d'un medley d'un pot pourri
c'est à dire qu'on ne part pas d'un
répertoire qu'on essaye d'organiser mais
on écrit un spectacle on conçoit un
spectacle les séquences je savais ce que
je voulais raconter et j'ai été chercher
tout ce qu'ils pouvaient ensuite entré
dans le récit ce qui fait qu
effectivement on assiste à une mini
comédie musicale mais c'est plutôt un
voyage un parcours et qui est
complètement scénarisé et mais on est
allé chercher même j'ai pas hésité à
mettre big flo et oli
stromae
bénabar un peu de temps en temps il ya
des passages on se dit ça a été écrit
pour le spectacle on va les écouter
toutes les trois
est la
même que c'était pas très bon avait rien
d'autre à l'homme
elle a eu raison et bien non
pourtant c'était pas terrible et ne pas
assaisonner c'est bien écrit dans la
bible a tant il est mal tombé
oui mais c'est la faute à
6h à seynod et puis adam a pris mes
rêves il avait bien sûr le haut est
valide attention curve id defla s'était
trop petit
est une grande feuille pour lui cacher
le zizi faire semblant d'être blonde
se maquiller le matin
voir les hanches bombes et
une bombe de satin
[Musique]
le miroir
exclusivement féminin
c'est excuser
wahaha
exclusivement
hier
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui a écrit les intermèdes
musicaux comme celui qu'on vient
d'entendre la sur adam et eve alors sauf
erreur de ma part grossière je pense que
c'est une chanson d'un sylvestre c'est
pas vrai si je me bats nan pas
complètement je pense que c'est donc
rien n'a été écrit spécialement pour le
spectacle non une seule chanson sinon on
est allé chercher mais je suis sûr aller
chercher vraiment par thème on a fait 1
devrait s'en expliquer je peux raconter
une petite histoire parce que elle est
jolie et le petit clip que vous avez
passé
a été ça a été fait le jour de la
première représentation devant 18
personnes à aix en provence en plein
confinement
on a quand même créé ce spectacle on
avait passé une salle de 60 places on a
le droit à un tir de la jauge de vie
j'étais 18 et on s'est dit on va le film
est à ce moment là ça n'est pas du tout
ce qui allait devenir ce spectacle dont
l'arrivée est au moment où on arrête de
se confiner ou ce avant qu'on sait trois
jours avant le confinement définitif
dont on avait encore le droit à un tiers
à un tiers et on a filmé on s'est dit
peut-être ça deviendra quelque chose et
un an et demi après vous nous recevez et
ces images là qu'on voit c'est assez
simple il est particulièrement dur de
fermes et où justement vous alliez
démaria spectacle ah ben ça a été vrai
mais ça a été horrible pour pour pour
tous de nombreux spectacles de nombreux
spectacles vous savez qu'il ya un
embouteillage monstre spectacle qu'ils
sont prêts actuellement qu'ils ont été
répétés et préparé pendant les divers
goûts filmant et c est qui et qui
attendent leur tour pour être joué mais
puisque vous me donnez la parole il faut
maintenant dire aux gens de venir de
devenir de sortir au théâtre et au
cinéma et dans les concerts et parce que
il ya une très grande désaffection du
public il faut le dire les gens ont tout
simplement appris à son passé et ses
aurait pas ce que vous ici vous vous
mettez en avant tout de la culture et
rod mais il faut absolument que les gens
on a besoin sinon ça va être ça va être
ça va être comme jean louis etienne tout
à l'heure ça va être terrible parce
qu'évidemment si elle perd une ip
pénurie public il y aura pénurie de
création de production et notre vie
culturelle qui est l'essentiel va
s'assécher donc il y à 50% des gens qui
sont encore ressortis
absolument mais est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est parce qu'ils en ont perdu
l'habitude qui n'ont plus goût c'est
parce qu'ils ont peur parce que bataille
à omikron
alors certains ont peut-être peur mais
heureusement vraiment je vais vous avez
diffusé une image de kienan on est en
tournée avec keane une pièce que j'ai
montée on accorde et fois de 500 600
personnes dans la salle donc je pense
que les gens n'ont pas si peur que ça
mais ce qui est beaucoup plus grave
c'est que certains ont appris à s'en
passer alors pour le cinéma n'en parlons
pas parce qu avec netflix et autres des
gens ont appris à voir ça chez eux alors
qu'ils veulent dans des conditions assez
favorable vous savez que les jeunes de
14 15 ans qui faisait le coeur du public
de cinéma une époque toute cette
génération là pendant deux ans n'a pas
été au cinéma et peut-être certaines
iront plus jamais au cinéma de leur vie
parce qu'ils ne savent pas ce que c'est
que d'être dans ce fauteuil devant un
immense écran avec du son magnifique des
images magnifiques et donc je pense que
parmi le public qui consomme est
vraiment de la culture des gens ont
totalement appris à s'en passer on a
appuyé les problèmes de se garer le soir
de d'être avec un match toute la journée
oui certes dans les salles de spectacle
il faut garder son masque mais c'est
grâce à ça que tous les salles de
spectacles sont ouvertes aujourd'hui et
avec george plein donc c'est bientôt les
fêtes il faut vraiment que le citoyen
prenne conscience de ça et aille au
spectacle qu'ils soient justement
explique bac vient de sortir sur west
side story ce retour
baba en flo mais le retour de comédie
musicale qu'on observe depuis quelques
années au cinéma la grande époque
c'étaient les années 30 au
et les années 40 à partir des 60
vraiment ça commença à devenir plus
rares les communes et musicale vous avez
l'impression que comédies musicales ont
changé qu'elles ont rapporté quelque
chose de nouveau aujourd'hui où c'est
une resucée de ce que l'on faisait il ya
30 ou 40 ans ah non non alors le la
france plus particulièrement a été assez
imperméable ce genre et c'est un genre
qui a qui n'a cessé d'évoluer la france
ne connaît que les grands shows comme
notre dame de paris comme des comédies
musicales sur scène sur cette voie là
mais
les productions de spectacles musicaux
la france en a fait peu parce que c'est
une très coûteux c'est tout de suite
frais coût de ces tournois et 2000 tout
à coup on découvre qu'on peut faire
c'est notre dame de paris c'est ali
bahamas absolument live puis ça dure
très peu de temps et puis ça s'arrête
très vite et puis ça ça mais mais non
mais c'est les français vont découvrir à
quel point c'est un plaisir absolu et
total puisque dans une même soirée vous
avez la joie l'émotion la musique la
danse le chant et est pas remis par les
temps qui courent les gens ont besoin de
choses légères et qui vous en vous même
très loin alors alexis michalik vient de
monter les producteurs que j'ai été voir
c'est absolument merveilleux et ça fait
un immense succès là pour le coup ça y
est les gens découvrent qu'une comédie
musicale peut raconter une vraie
histoire n'est pas simplement un
assemblement de chansons c'est une cité
des spectacles qui vous emmène très très
loin un dernier extrait des swing
cocktail c'est quand vous visiblement
vous êtes tombé sur une chanson de hip
hop
[Musique]
oh
camélia lady gaga c'est le même combat
ils pop opéra un amour qui d'un philippe
et dieu créa le swing s'est prolongée
jusqu'en avril au théâtre de la comédie
bastille et puis ça ensuite ce sera en
tournée dans toute la france absolument
et avignon cet été et avignon cet été
bien sûr
[Musique]
pierre verville vous publiez la ville d
annecy est qu'ils ont avec une préface
de yann moix un promoteur immobilier
tombe de la tour de 15 étages qu'il
vient d'inaugurer à asnières mais
attention ça n'est pas un roman policier
comme le dit le quatrième de couverture
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas le policier le
héros comme dans les romans de simenon
ni même le détective privé comme chez
agatha christie
c'est un pur roman noir avec les
vieilles ficelles qui ont fait le succès
du roman noir dans les années 30 aux
etats unis une femme fatale un mari
riche un amant naïf mais que vous
accommoder bien entendu à la sauce
d'aujourd'hui c'était votre volonté
écrit un roman noir tout à fait tout à
fait je trouve que depuis toujours je
trouve que le roman noir ça c'est un
genre délicieux intéressant qui met la
lèpre un divertissement un regard
souvent ironiques sur le monde tragique
et tragique en même temps eric équipe a
le monde douar el tel qu'il est donc on
peut à la fois avoir les ressorts du
roman de l' aventure de l'amour la
découverte est en même temps les les
les ressorts de la société dans laquelle
on sent même temps dans l'impression que
ça peut nous arriver à nous puisque dans
le roman noir c'est pas les gangsters
c'est pas les laisser ce dossier c'est
c'est des gens comme vous et moi c'est
vrai c'est ce que j'aime bien dans le
roman noir ce jeu suit mais ça n'engage
que moi un peu fatigué d'aider des super
héros des polars des super héros de ceux
des choses fantastiques des univers
improbable des monstres très monstrueux
des méchants plus méchante nature de
l'époque de bill de l' angoisse c'est
très à la mode d'ailleurs un peu moins
ça fonctionne mais ça fonctionne très
bien c'est pas mon truc moi j'aime bien
que l aventure soit au coin de la rue
d'ailleurs je laime énorme admiration
pour le pour le docteur etienne qui lui
lui va loin il va très très très très
très loin moi j'ai pas du tout cette
cette cape et les en même temps je lis
cette vision très noire très tragique de
la société des individus qui la peuplent
or dans une ancienne vie vous étiez
publicitaire là au contraire il faut
avoir une vision angélique de là alors à
quel moment est ce que vous êtes forcé
pas dans une ancienne vie j'étais
publicitaires mais c'est un publicitaire
qui aimez écrire et qui est médias donc
l'écriture ça m'a toujours accompagné
elle c'est vrai que c'était plutôt
d'ailleurs à prendre et repensant du
côté à trouver des slogans à trouver des
films publicitaires avec des scénarios
assez écrit des dialogues et c'est ça ma
tous les sons ils sombrent déjà non
c'est un peu surprenant non sombre non
mais attention la ville des hans est un
roman qui est sombre dans sa forme non
c'est sombre dans son esprit comme didot
on n'est pas là pour ennuyer des
populations en vue des produits et
d'ailleurs elle avait d'ailleurs c'est
très intéressant puisque dans ce trio
que je décrivais vous avez le le mari
riche ça c'est une obligation d'usagé en
2de beaucoup de romans noirs pour lui
c'est un promoteur immobilier
vous l'avez fait comme souvent les
mariés riches dans le roman noir à
priori ils ont à la fois un petit côté
voyou et un petit côté exactement mais
mon envie d'amener leurs côtés c'est
très intéressant sas d'être on peut pas
le condamner le mari riche parce que tu
sais qui va avoir des problèmes et on
doit être un peu de son côté quand même
tout à fait je crois qu'on peut
condamner personne qu'on écrit un roman
surtout pas roman noir j'ai aucune
originalité je suis un amoureux
inconditionnel de flaubert
flaubert il jugeait pas il laisser ça
aux jeux je vais jouer le jeu il ne
jugeait pas ses personnages je pense
qu'un romancier il gagne beaucoup quand
il juge pas ces personnages on les
laisse aller ça sert à rien d'être
manichéen c'est vrai que c'est des
personnages intéressants et vous avez
raison de souligner cette cette
filiation avec les romans noirs
traditionnels
ça pourrait être un challenge
a le niveau de l'adriq d'ailleurs je
m'en suis clairement clairement inspiré
mais à chaque fois comme tous les grands
genres on peut renouveler le genre et
trouver de rendre plus contemporain plus
étonnant avec des accessoires de mode
vous avez choisi et d'aujourd'hui dans
le rôle de l'amant naïfs qui a le
notaire et oui le notaire c'est une
figure très littéraire c'est georges
duhamel évidemment le notaire du havre
mais aussi chez flaubert chez balzac
chez chez qui j'ai retrouvé la biche
père aussi c'est même le héros de
dracula c'est un docteur janet depuis
ces deux aussi des héros de faits divers
j'ai trouvé que les notaires c'est des
personnes à cheveux très intéressant
parce que inattendu vous d'essayer le
souci de l'exactitude y est fondamentale
et voltaire il faut qu'il y ait une
évolution dans un personnage donc ça m'a
beaucoup intéressé ce côté obsessionnel
de que doivent avoir les notaires par
une obligation professionnelle et qui
peu à peu vont se fissurer sous la
pression des événements et puis il ya la
femme fatale alors elle s'appelle alice
son surnom c'est ice elle est comme
toutes les femmes fatales un moule et
d'après les manuels absolument bonne en
tout
vous allez faire des ennemis très
intelligente tellement intelligente même
qu'elle cache un peu de son intelligence
pour ne pas effrayer les hommes et les
aimants composé plutôt que combattre
c'est vrai c'est vrai alors c'est en
cela
certaines considèrent qu'on ne sait pas
forcément une une féministe une
féministe
pour moi c'est peut-être une féministe
parce que elle finit par trop par
triompher elle utilise les armes de la
féminité et de l'intelligence féminine
pour moi je trouve que c'est un
personnage très intéressant d'une façon
générale les femmes la déteste les ob
l'adorent alors elle dit un truc que
j'ai trouvé très intéressant les
rejetons des grandes familles sont
devenus insipide et peureux adieu les
folles nuits du xxème siècle seuls les
rapports en vue se risque encore à
dépasser les bornes donc qu'elle préfère
finalement les self made man comme celui
qu'elle épouse elle son mari ce
promoteur immobilier
nous avons encore voilà ils sont plus
amusants dont font les fils de c'est
plus possible que
les temps ont changé les temps ont
changé aujourd'hui effectivement on
trouve on trouve chez certains mauvais
garçons en col blanc c'est un roman sur
la banlieue aussi c'est à dire c'est
important c'est important de le dire
pour moi bon ça remet au noir ça remonte
d'abord on l'a évoqué mais c'est aussi
un roman sur l'amour de la banlieue et
la banlieue c'est pas forcément celle
des bars enfin deux r e s encore c'est
le débat n'est pas où on va boire un
coup des dealers et c'est la banlieue
toutes les banlieues d'ailleurs diamètre
la banlieue de paris toutes les grandes
villes ont des ondées banlieue c'est
c'est des endroits qui sont des endroits
qui aurait mérité d'être mieux préservé
qui aurait mérité de 2,2 de rester un
petit peu dans leurs charmes dans le cas
daniels et les potes c'est les
impressionnistes le cas d'amiens on en
parle beaucoup dans dans le roman
évidemment c'est les impressionnistes je
crois qu'il ya une phrase qui définit
pas mal je crois que ce que j'ai voulu
dire qui dit autrefois il y avait des
peintres des îles maintenant il n'y a
plus qu'on troubles et puisque la scène
le peigner les impressionnistes passa
passa à d'hyères effectivement ça
entraîner des populations différentes
manières c'est une ville très très
intéressante parce que c'est extrêmement
mélanger des architectures sont mélangés
les cuisines sont mélangés les
populations sont mélangés il ya des
ouvriers il ya des riches il ya des
pauvres il ya des bobos ya pas ça a été
complètement transformé par une sorte
d'art immobilière il semble ailleurs et
si justement alors ça c'est un petit peu
le côté justement un rebond douar social
de du livre c'est que tout le long de la
seine se sont élevés et continuent à le
faire un certain nombre de tours ou
d'immeubles assez haut ça entraînait un
certain nombre de conséquences ça ça
déstabilise un peu le sous sol parce que
c'était des berges à give you nerfs donc
donc assez assez peu fait pour avoir des
cibles au seo aussi hausse à abîmer les
pavillons autour enfin ça a modifié sa
modifiait physiquement la ville mais ça
me dit fier aussi les mentalités ça
amenait des populations nouvelles et
toute une population finalement
d'arrivistes de deux nouveaux riches de
bobo enfin je dis pas que c'est laid
mais ils s'ajoutent les uns aux autres
et que c'est que c'est un bon terreau
pour pour raconter ça elle est quand
même très anti féministe votre femme
fatale puisqu'elle déclare qu' elle
pourrait l'être je lis ou être riche
c'est pareil aux femmes d'être jolie aux
hommes d'être origine
les hommes consomment et nous nous
consommons le monde grâce à ses
l'histoire de ce personnage là les
langues les personnes achetant je pense
qu'il ya encore des femmes qui payent
qui réfléchissent comme ça mais elle est
tellement intelligente on se dit ils
auraient pu se passer des hommes
c'est son choix mais c'est son choix
j'ai découvert vraiment une vérité de
beaucoup de rebonds sied exprime c'est
que on ne fait pas forcément ce qu'on
veut de ses personnages voyagent ya un
moment où les personnages qui finissent
par faire ce qu'ils veulent que d'eau
lui encore
c'est le travail du romancier c'est un
peu le meneur doit qui essaye de garder
dans le droit chemin de son histoire des
personnages qui pense qu'à partir de
s'égailler dans tous les sens cette
fable as et des scripts décrite s imposé
à moi d'où vient-elle je ne sais pas je
ne la connais pas personnellement et
doivent élire probablement mon
inconscient d'un certain nombre
d'observations
je suis content qu'elle soit pas tout à
fait convenu je suis content qu'il soit
pas tout à fait de notre époque c'est
c'est magnifique de deux sortes de
réussir à sortir de soi un personnage
qui suit pas à la lettre les préceptes
du moment à la saxe puisque vous là vous
êtes attaqués au répertoire féminin avec
les swings cocktail est ce qu'on peut
encore présenter des personnages
féminins
à l'ancienne qui répondent pas aux
exigences d'aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
est interdit d'interdire
et c'est très intéressant parce que je
n'invente invité didier van cauwelaert
avec qui j'ai beaucoup travaillé et
rencontre un auteur j'essaie de savoir
et de comprendre et je me dis mais alors
tu fais des tu fais des plans comment ça
marche et ça et il m'a dit exactement ce
que vous venez de dire c'est qu'il ya un
moment où celle et les personnages
l'histoire à collo l'auteur peut avoir
prévu un certain nombre de choses et il
ya un moment où tout lui échappe et
savent sort d'on ne sait où est
justement à partir de là on peut
imaginer que ce qui sort doit sortir
même si c'est absolument pas en accord
fasa normes avec les normes etc c'est
quand même ça qui fait toute la
littérature non puisqu'ils
n'ont jamais été en phase avec les
normes mais alors dernière question
piège ville vous avez le baril vous
riche vous avez la femme fatale vous
avez le meilleur ami du mari qui devient
l'amant naïf à partir de ce moment-là et
dès l'instant où on sait qu'ils soient
membres vous savez bien comme on a lu
des romans noirs qu'on sait à peu près
ce qu'il va se passer elle va lui
proposer de tuer et aideront la vie dans
des cases millwood a fait comment on
sort de ça c'est à dire que aux libres
normalement là le livre est déjà tout
écrit oui il a été écrit de cette
manière là si souvent c'est vrai que
comment on fait pour mon sens c'est vrai
mais c'est peut-être pas par hasard
qu'il ya eu des centaines de livres
écrits sur cette trame de départ cette
table de départ après après comme on le
disait les personnages prennent un prêt
de leur autonomie sont un petit peu
différent ça notaire donc ça donne lieu
sa salive d'amusement gp trip hop hop ça
pour qu'on s'ennuie en lisant j'ai écrit
un livre comme j'aurais comme j'aime
lire les livres que j'aime mais en même
temps c'est un livre assez documenté
donc il ya craint quand il existe un
élément documentaire dans un livre à nos
terres c'est intéressant aussi pour sa
commissaire où un flic c'est parce que
il est c'est intéressant de connaître la
ville à noter on en connaît à peu près
qu'ils soient notaire c'est que
différentes de s'il avait été sur voilà
donc savoir où c'est là où on l ait fait
un livre un petit peu différent a fait
ça se passe à asnières là où il ya les
ans les des impressionnistes là où
habitait caillebotte aux petits
gennevilliers qui était qui était qui
dépend des deux de l'église dadian etc
etc ça crée un livre un petit peu
différent et on peut pas tout réinventer
ses biens en même temps vous savez bien
que sans le spolier la fin n'a rien à
voir toutes les femmes qu'on a pu lire
çà c'est venu comme ça j'ai
effectivement je pense que là la fin
pour le court rejoint notre époque merci
beaucoup tous les deux d'avoir participé
c'est participer à cette émission la
ville des hans est sorti chez qui l'on
et dieu créa le swing c'est jusqu'au
bout en avril au théâtre de la comédie
bastille et puis jean louis etienne nous
a quittés tout à l'heure mais
explorateur des océans c'est paru chez
paulsen merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]